if a plant has enough water minerals and
energy it will grow right well sort of
but there is more to it like why do
plants bend towards the light and not
just grow straight and why is it that
the stem grows up but the roots grow
down
it isn't as if the plant has eyes to
tell it where the sun is
you should already know about tropisms
so phototropism and geotropism but if
you have forgotten watch our video
called plant hormones tropisms first
but how does it actually do this having
been made in the tips of the stems and
roots auxin is moved in solution by
diffusion to older parts of the plant in
the stem the auxin causes the cells to
change in elasticity
more elastic cells absorb more water and
can grow longer strangely though stems
and roots respond differently to high
concentrations of auxin
whilst the stem cells grow more the root
cells actually grow less so auxins make
plants grow
but why do they bend towards the light
how do they know to do this when they
don't have eyes
the bending happens because the light
hits on one side more and breaks down
the auxins on that side of the stem
so then growth slows down on the light
side the faster growth on the dark side
causes the shoots and leaves to turn
towards the light which is ideal for the
plant for photosynthesis
auxin is produced in the tips of growing
shoots
if the tips are cut off
then no auxin can be produced and so no
plant growth if the tips are covered
whilst auxin is still produced light
cannot break it down and so phototropism
cannot occur
the plant just grows straight up and
does not bend towards the light pretty
straightforward so far now let's switch
it up a bit auxins have the opposite
effect on root cells in roots
auxins cause less growth the shaded side
of roots contain more auxin and so they
grow less
this enables the light side of the roots
to grow more and bend away from the
light and if that wasn't weird enough we
have the opposite happening with auxins
to gravity too in a horizontal route the
bottom side contains more auxin and
grows less
so the root bends downwards in the
direction of gravity so positive
geotropism but of course the stem
responds differently
in a horizontal stem
again the bottom side contains more
auxins because it is less directly hit
by sunlight
but because auxins cause growth in stems
the bottom side grows more causing the
stem to bend upwards against the
direction of gravity so negative
geotropism
but i'm giving auxins too much credit
they don't work alone
they have a partner in crime
cytokinins
you don't need to know anything about
these hormones
other than the fact that they work
alongside auxins there is another plant
hormone however that you do need to be
aware of
gibberellins
once the seed germinates the roots and
shoots start to grow
but for this the seed needs energy
luckily the seed releases a hormone
called gibberellin
which causes the starch in the seed to
turn into sugars and provides the seed
with energy to grow
as well as causing shoot growth
gibberillins can also stimulate
flowering and the production of fruit in
some plants and they also work with
auxins to cause stem elongation
so now we know all about how plant
hormones work have a think about how
they could be used
we will discover some uses in our video
on how we use plant hormones